he tweeted a guideline to rational's
discourse basics of rationalist
discourse from less wrong what are these
folks what's rationalist culture what's
the rationalize this course
uh yeah I love their astronauts because
they're interested like how do you have
conversations more effectively if you're
trying to figure out what's actually
true
and which sounds kind of obvious but in
practice it's not usually
um I remember when I first started
having you know debating conversations I
was very antagonistic I'm like oh I'm
you know a feminist or not a feminist
and then the rationalists were generally
like actually we don't know what we mean
by the term feminism let's like how do
you feel about that it was it was very
like uh kind and compassionate like even
if somebody said something that sounds
insane you're like okay well we're going
to respect your reasoning and like even
if we disagree let's actually figure out
why you think the way that you think
um and they're also really smart write a
whole bunch of great stuff about how to
think more clearly and with less bias
yeah I wonder what those conversations
because I never really like talked to
those folks
so this guideline particular I think has
to refers to like shorthand
characteristics of rationalist discourse
um including expect good discourse to
require energy don't say
straightforwardly false Things Track for
yourself and distinguish for others your
inferences from your observations
estimate for yourself and make clear for
others your rough level of confidence in
your assertions make your claims clear
explicit and falsifiable or explicitly
acknowledge that you aren't doing so or
can't
so on and so forth so don't jump to
conclusions
don't weaponize equivocation don't abuse
categories don't engage it's very
aggressive guidelines don't engage I do
what I want I let my emotions guide me
God damn it they're Pro that as long as
you're explicit about it oh yeah yeah
so you can be like a crazy as
long as you're explicit you can be like
epistemic status crazy who's
here to destroy the the the quality of
the conversation I think it's like a
common misconception about rationalists
is that they're kind of like Spock like
ah we used to press emotion we're
thinking logically hurt eater but I
found this to be really not the case
like I remember there's a less strong
thread where I was like really emotional
and I commented and at the beginning I
was like just warning I'm just very
emotional and then I just vented my
emotions and people respond really well
to that they're like cool like you're
just genuinely truthfully expressing
your state this is actual information
about the world it is important to hear
and it's just they're very interested in
having things framed correctly like you
shouldn't be claiming that your emotions
are necessarily a true version of the
world and so as long as you're just
clear about what the frame it is you're
fine
how do you feel about this conversation
what could we have done better
I like the conversation
I was a little worried coming and I was
like what if he'll only asked a couple
questions and then we don't always talk
about yeah but it's been in quite a long
time and I I covered there's so many
things I didn't cover
I like the you have like a like I'm not
used to talking to somebody who feels
like some of the core way that they
approach the world are so different than
mine like usually the differences that
arrive like higher up the tree but like
there's something about like your root
system that I think is very different
from mine but also the way that you
engage with others is still flexible
like usually when I encounter somebody
with such a different root system
there's like it's like more aggressive
or something yeah but there's something
about the way that you're structured
that feels very gentle
all right
well I'm really happy we talked
something tells me we'll probably talk a
bunch more times I think you're a
fascinating human being I think I'm a
huge fan of your work uh maybe one more
question what's the meaning of life
to want things to to search
to be in
well I think your curiosity is like
somehow getting to that yeah to one
thing it's like curiosity like you don't
know I want to know the answer to like
be in the state of Yearning of wanting
yeah I wonder if you could do that if
you lived a million years just keep
yearning always that's the thing I'm
probably afraid of if I live just a
million years it's not the torture it's
like the yearning will fade you're
probably yearned to die then
I was just sitting there
wanting death intensely
that's kind of romantic a little bit it
has like a a bit of that spark
and constantly being denied wow
so most of your existence on Earth would
be spent deeply
intimate with death just thinking about
death
I think we're already doing that but if
I like hiding that from ourselves a
little bit anyway wanting
well
this is an amazing conversation I think
you're an amazing researcher and human
being you're a great interviewer
I can see why you do this a lot I
appreciate it this is really fun Ella
thank you so much for talking with me
today thank you